president Trump finally made it to
Puerto Rico I went to Puerto Rico good
friend yeah that's right president Trump
was in Puerto Rico today to survey the
hurricane damage yeah
Trump looked around then told the locals
if I were you I'd go stay at your second
homes I think that would be that we
should go where your third he's got the
common touch to raise me this is where
to raise money for Puerto Rico
celebrities have been posting pictures
online of themselves from puberty yes
however after one look at mine Puerto
Rico said haven't we been through enough
actually yeah yeah we'll put it up -
this is me from just if you're curious
that's yeah yeah that was yeah me when I
was yes that's when I was going from
girl to woman
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and not feeling too great about it ela
Wow look at him again he's like someday
they'll love me oh and with a shirt like
that I couldn't miss what else is going
on Sports News there's a rumor that the
Lakers are trying to sign LeBron James
yeah
yeah they're telling him the weather in
LA is great Plus as a Laker you get the
entire playoff season off
crazy story in the news crazy story
scientists have figured out how to
generate electricity from tears yes in
fact they say that soon 10% of our
energy will come from people watching
this is us yeah you better like the joke
because that's the little boy that told
them right there there if you don't like
if you don't like a joke you're hurting
that little guys feeling
hey there's talk of including video
gamers in future Olympics they might add
video games yeah yeah limpid gamers
would be treated like all other athletes
except they'd be tested for
performance-enhancing Ramen
hey Germany's in the news Germany has
just rolled out a new law banning hate
speech isn't that great
Germany is banning 8p yeah yeah the law
is the lost tricky to implement because
everything sounds like hate speech when
it's spoken in German noggin yes I will
give you a soft-serve cone this is crazy
the new food craze in Thailand is penis
shaped waffles I'm not making that up
penis shaped waffles yeah the waffles
come in three sizes small medium and
liam neeson yeah apparently if you
finish the Liam Neeson and you get a
free t-shirt so
I wish I had enacted that one out yeah
that's kinda just ate a penis walk right
right yeah and I forgot that it was a
penis yeah waffle and it's Liam Neeson
specifically yeah well yeah that's a
good part all right listen I I don't
even know what's happening anymore right
sometimes there's parts of the show
where people were just giggling and the
show's drifting and we're all like I
don't know
you know yeah yeah but no one's getting
hurt so you know it's fine
you